[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you tapped into the group chat live by
la presented by
fanduel live in the bleacher report app
the nba is back i'm so excited we're all
so excited it feels like yesterday it
feels like forever ago
but your winning moments are immortal
have a look
[Music]
i'm so hyped my name is cabby richards
in the middle that is our betting expert
kelly stewart
and on the on the end is a man who only
interacts with winners only please that
is greg ivory
listen kelly and greg we have a huge
announcement to make
on today's group chat last season as you
know
on the iconic inside the nba charles
barkley was throwing out guarantees
all over the place and when he did it
didn't go well
the nuggets are going to win tonight i
guarantee it this one belongs to the
utah jazz
indiana pacers
the miami heat knock off the indiana
pacers
in a 4-0 opening round sweep the
portland trail blazers win tonight
they're going to sweep the lakers
[Music]
los angeles lakers in five the milwaukee
bucks
are going to the conference finals
guaranteed
that's it the milwaukee bucks lose
that one like two like three
he always puts a smile on my face man uh
so we reached out to charles barkley
uh and we told him we're tired of his
empty guarantees and we asked him to put
his mouth
or put his money where his mouth is so
every week we're going to put a poll out
on social like we did earlier this week
and we asked you
who's going to score more points in
tuesday's golden state warriors
versus brooklyn nets game stephen curry
or
kevin durant and as you can see the
current lead
is barely uh kevin durant it's basically
50 50 but durant has the
one percent lead so you still have you
still have time to get in there
and cast your vote and whatever you vote
for we
ride with so and then on the pre-game
show charles barkley can either ride
with us
or he can fade us it's up to him um but
one thing to note is
if we have a better record all of us
together than charles barkley
then we're going to celebrate with
something special so definitely stay
tuned for that
get in the comments and let us know uh
who's who you think will score most more
points
in brooklyn and golden state stephen
curry or kevin durant
g money greg ivory you are the bay area
resident so we'll have you start first
curry durant who you got
i had to take a deep breath there
because cabbie this one's tough
this one's really really really really
tough
my heart says steph curry
steph he needs to have an mvp type
season this year if the warriors want to
make the playoffs this season
steph needs to he he needs the ball he
has the ball he has to turn into the old
steph curry
uh back in the day 2015 2016 steph curry
okay
uh if the warriors want to make the
playoffs but you're my let's talk
telling you what now let's talk about
now hold up hold on kathy hold on hold
on cabbie now there's a bad man
that plays for brooklyn now a bad bad
man by the name of kevin durant and he's
sitting at plus value right here
kelly she loves her value she's always
talking to me about value
i cannot pass kd with plus
value at plus 120. i just can't pass it
so with that being said my heart's
telling me stuff
but my mind's telling me hey d and the
value is too
kelly what is your mind telling you
i think you can look at this a couple of
different ways kathy one of the things
that first comes to mind is minus 150
for steph are they going to double team
steph today because
he is the number one weapon for the
golden state warriors on the flip side
kevin durant has to share the ball with
another great player named kyrie so i
have my concerns
i do think that greg is kind of right in
terms of
value here the plus 120 looks enticing
i think that's where i've got to go wait
a second okay so you
rarely i mean we just saw the poll 51 of
our audience
leaning kevin durant and you rarely side
with the public
so are you comfortable with picking kd
in game one
i wouldn't exactly say this is siding
with the public it's like
one percent two percent there's some
variance there
look i don't purposely fade the public i
think that's what's a really funny thing
is people think that just happens to be
i'm on the opposite side it's like greg
i happen to be
on the opposite side of greg a lot it's
not like i'm mean for that to happen
i'm happy that it happens actually yeah
hey i got to shout out
an og bay area legend e40 who was doing
the shimmy
on the verses and then we saw steph
curry doing his little shimmy
and i'm a big fan so i had to go i saw
these on vr kicks so i had to go pick
these up
and so you know exactly who i'm riding
with in game one i'm riding with steph
curry
because he's he's about to drop 30 plus
against the nets
okay because the the the pedal is to the
metal full throttle
uh all right america get on twitter and
tell us which side you want us to ride
with
check out the pre-game show on tnt with
chuck to see what he picks
so send us your videos send us your
reaction videos send us your talking
trash to charles barkley videos
and there's a chance you'll be featured
on the post game of the iconic
inside the nba and uh they might show
your video and you might even
grab a piece of the 30 million that
fanduel and charles barkley
are giving out this year 30 mil it's
gonna be awesome
all right so um right now it's time to
reconnect
with uh the only gambler more infamous
than charles barkley and as i check my
notes
uh the hammer lock legend himself
mikey locks let's bring him in on the
fanduel hotline
lox talk to us baby
i am slinging absolute hammer locks all
year cabbie what are you talking about
we're back listen uh
locks like you you you rarely listen to
kelly's advice so i
before we get into things where did you
end up do you end up even
with betting on both the lakers and the
miami heat
you had a clippers future you had the
bucks you were betting all over the
place did you break even bro
cavi you are we're not here to talk
about the past 2020 rear view mirror
we're here to focus on future absolute
camera locks for 2021.
that's the first thing i'll say the
second thing i'll say kelly you got to
stop fading the public and you got to
stop fading the group chat okay we're
here as a family
to get rich this is a different show
hey i'm sorry the note i got from the
producer
was lay the hammer you know take
no no seriously like take no mercy on
these guys i want you to just be
yourself that's what he said so that's
what i'm here to do
uh and it's uh we already sounded like a
family it's been a couple months but we
definitely saw my family listen uh mikey
you introduced the world
to nerfies you uh you were the
self-proclaimed
fur boo guru shout out to javale mcgee
who helped you cash
a bunch of tickets last year for the los
angeles lakers
for the adrenaline junkies that need a
hit right after the tip off
we go we look to you for our quick
hitters so what did you bring for us
today
okay first of all not self-proclaimed
cabbie again the loch ness monsters were
saying i heard greg and kelly say it one
time
the nerfey king is back and we have been
working with fanduel
you have the new nerfey if you guys
don't know what the nerf is no runs
first inning we got
rich during baseball resolves five ten
minutes
we have this for the nba this year
fanduel has hooked us up go to fanduel
look in their boost section uh the br
betting 3x2 boost
will there be two three-point field
goals scored in the first
three minutes of warriors versus nets
this is what we are going to
hammer tomorrow night we will be
hammering it every thursday night of the
nba season
we are taking yes you know that kd staff
kyrie are going to be firing and we're
going to have a lot of fun cause it's
going to resolve real quick
and win or lose we're going to be doing
some some screaming at the tv
g money are you are you riding with your
dude mikey locks
tabby is the sky blue
most of the time of course i'm riding
with mikey locks
i mean i definitely see two threes
happening
in the first three minutes we got the
golden state warriors and do you want me
to name some roster players
steph curry kelly ubray wiggins
i can keep going if you want me to
because they got strengthened numbers
this year
but let's talk about let's talk about
the brooklyn nets as well
kd kyrie i mean then witty
i can keep going about them too they got
it i mean they got
shooters out there they also got hall of
fame players on the court
definitely do they got shooters out
there though so i'm definitely seeing
two threes in the first i'm just i'm
just checking my notes that's the first
time spencer didwitty's ever been
mentioned in
uh any of these streams so uh
congratulations my dude
i need i like i need a rationale i need
a rational perspective
he's a ballerina but he's not gonna be
shooting three-pointers anyway
uh kelly stewart are are you where where
are you leaning on this one this is the
first time in my life i've ever been
called rational but i get it look who
we're dealing with here
no and look they're right if when we get
a
fan dual odds boost it's like they're
almost wanting to give you free money
this should be
minus 180 maybe minus two dollars so
plus 110 i feel like this is a really
good bet i do think
there will be at least two if not more
three-pointers made in the first three
minutes
three minutes that's a long time i got
to go with the ass cabinets
jack goes up we will just be losing our
mind i'm so excited for this
i'm i'm excited that mikey locks has the
hammer mustache again
and you know what the their energy's
infectious so i'm riding with the boys
i think that joe harris and kd
and steph curry will give you three
three-pointers in the first two minutes
those are our perspectives g-money i
know you're you're tapped in with the
commenters
tell us what the audience how they're
reacting i'm in the comments and my guy
bobby reno is all over me mikey mikey
check this one out
he says joe harris we miss joe harris
the three-point champion
i do agree i do agree he's a baller and
he's he's a sharp shooter
uh he mike tell him he's gonna he's
gonna be probably
one of the guys that's gonna be able to
knock one of these threes down okay you
three stops
we don't want to see anything in the
post we want to spread it out and we
want to just
start with a very high plate that's all
we care about do not
dump the ball down low bobby i love that
you just want people just chop
chucking up threes mike like you just
don't even care just keep chucking them
up go
go go bobby bobby reno you're walking
away with a hoodie guys let me get back
into these comments i gotta give the
people what they want
lou bannon the 95 says for sure
two threes in the first three minutes
and it's gonna be joe harris and steph
they're confirming what we just said
mikey joe harris steph curry love it
i'm back into the comments giving away
some more hoodies uh
i got i got mjm1122 if there's not two
threes in the first
three minutes there's a huge problem i
agree with you there brother because
that means
me and mikey will not be winning our
bets uh
cabbie you're in you're in on this too
yeah me mike and cabbie will not be one
of the best everybody i said you guys
are walking away
with hoodies uh cabbie yeah let's move
on okay
listen uh we gotta and shout out to
steve nash and his
offensive coordinator mike d'antoni
three-pointers
we can book them uh lox we need to talk
nba futures
uh here are the favorite future bets
we got uh a lot of confidence and last
year
you were all you were you bet on the
lakers with the bucks
you had the clippers here's the ball
right we're way past it
uh interestingly on the other side of
the bracket kelly what do you make of
luca donches being the
the 2021 mvp leader
right now or facebook it makes sense
what did we see
last he he's listed as a favorite
because the bookmakers know a ton of
money is going to come in on him so they
priced him cheaper
than he probably should be now the
reason why is because he
absolutely put on a performance against
the los angeles clippers as we saw in
the bubble and people remember that
he is the front runner probably for a
reason but i feel like he's
we're not getting quite the value maybe
it's six to one seven to one
i would look at it there but i feel like
the bookmakers are kind of baiting you
in there right they just toss out a
little hook like oh we know you want to
put a little bet on luca
and it might not end well for you so i'm
leaning towards giannis once again but
of course mikey locks is going to
sprinkle on luca
listen uh lots your your future strategy
made no sense
as i was saying you had clippers bucks
lakers
whatever uh and on top of it i told you
some guy
this is like the fourth whole night so
no told you some guy that told you
something
wait a second on top of that when you
cash big checks
your butt has to cash when you uh yeah
your butt has to catch them
um when you talk a big game sorry
with it with this group this group of
friends sometimes
uh these things happen to you
you're gonna look better than mike fires
did when he had half of his
that's it stop right there yes this is
funny to you
that was one of the highlights of the
year right there like this is this i
think i haven't
laughed that hard since that day i need
i need some more
mikey locks bets look um you've had a
couple of with the real
ben stiller happy gilmore handlebars
just to prove that
put that moment in the past that was
really rough times for me i think i aged
about 10 years since then
uh and we've been laughing for 10 years
you've had a couple of months to think
about it
um and if your future lock doesn't hit
are
are we shaving your eyebrows are we
shaving your head are you finally
going to man up and get a group chat
tattoo on your lower back
um excuse me hold on sorry cabbie i i
don't mean to interrupt um but i think
there was a time
maybe in april when there wasn't any
sports going on we were doing these uh
madden simulations don't you already owe
me a goat tattoo mikey
i always pay my debts the goat touch
will get paid i have one for you this
year
it's been seven months okay seven months
we're gonna get a little boga special
well buy one get one if i get this wrong
and we'll get it get a full sleeve about
that i'll get a full
ass tap sleeve if this bet doesn't hit
deal i heard greg ivory greg ivory's got
a guy we'll just send him right over he
can do it in your kitchen
i live 20 minutes away i live 20 minutes
away from you micah
i got a guy tattoo guy we can come over
you know
real real real masked up and everything
we can get that done man we can get that
date
depending depending on how this three by
two goes i might need a little 25
off friends and family discount you let
me know greg
oh it's all good you know me i'll pay
for it i'm not worried about what it
costs
i will fly you to vegas if you keep
making an excuse because i know our
tattoo shops are open yeah do you want
the hammer locks
yes i have it what do you got if it does
not hit i will get
live laugh lock tattooed on my butt
cheek along with the goat tattoo kelly
don't worry this will hit the
the warriors we've been talking about
them a little bit i know greg's gonna
like this
minus 158 to make the playoffs call your
bank maybe get a little refi
going maybe a little refi maybe call
grandma get irritants a little
early do whatever you got to do but i
personally
am going to be hammering this this is a
hammerlock if not
level flock attached to 500
e z i can't believe mikey likes you
that's scary
mortgaging mortgaging your house
i don't know how any of that works to be
honest with you
yo lox thanks for joining us man we're
going to check in with you in the next
couple of weeks
all right emily i love you all let's get
rich let's stay together okay no told
you so guy
no fading the group chat let's stay
together as a family and lock i love you
all
let's get rich hey uh g-money
uh how's the audience reacting to the
mustache shaving
locky's pr lots of proclamations about
the tattoo
give us a sense hey my guy uh my guy
danny brasco is in the comments saying
that i got a sketchy tattoo guy easy
easy my guy he's qualified no no no see
this is the thing i want it to be nice
i want this is going to be on him
forever like i think the beautiful font
with like the big
l and the really nice go like next i i
want it to be a nice piece
i don't want it to be a trash tattoo
i'm back into the comments though i'm
back into the comments joe yan winners
only nuggets over win total
joe please say a please please say the
please
winners only you're getting a hoodie uh
i got
i got i got mr th the mr og i think he
and aaron rodgers were separated at
birth he's talking about mikey
uh yeah i like that i show him mikey a
little love so i'm gonna give him hoodie
let's get back into this
i see people there i see i see a lot of
different
uh teams that that that they're riding
with on their futures but
uh you know what cabbie i'm just gonna
give out comments
i'm just i'm just going to give out
hoodies i'm sorry dsarty you're getting
a hoodie marky mark you're getting a
hoodie
uh danny brasco you're getting a hoodie
slick nick 26 you're getting a hoodie
kevin whenever you want me okay
i only have one i only have one issue
with one with what one of the commenters
said
like the the difference the big
difference between aaron rodgers is my
and mikey locks as aaron rodgers
actually wins
and wins in life right i don't know i
don't know
on
you're the guy that like after they
leave the group chat where you make fun
of them the whole time that's terrible
cabbie
i may have a little bit a little bit of
dirt under my fingernails okay listen
uh tuesday tuesday the lakers face the
clippers
uh and uh the clippers have replaced the
golden state warriors as greg's favorite
team to blow a 3-1 lead
thank you very much denver nuggets uh
listen last year the audience got rich
on same game parlay same game parlays
we did not unfortunately so greg since
you've been crushing it on winners only
wednesdays
kelly and i have decided to let you
build our single game parlays
for the rest of the year so g-money
let's build this bank
uh you see me stretching yeah right now
because
it's about time you guys gave me the
keys
it's about time you got we didn't win
any last year we didn't win not one
it's about time we get in the winning
column because you guys know
what i asked for i asked for winners
only
please that's all that i ask for and
that's what we're gonna do i'm actually
guaranteeing
that we win at least one of these this
season
guarantees why would you do that why
would you guarantee
that we're gonna you mean we're gonna
lose some confidence
great huh great great great great greg
first of all now you just jinxed
yourself way to go second of all
i will bet you a nickel 500
real american dollars none of that stuff
from where cabbies from
real american dollars that you do not
hit one of these
five leg same team
parlays it's not gonna happen i'm sorry
you're not gonna do it
kelly guess what you got yourself a bet
because
we are gonna hit it and kelly see this
is this is this is where
you don't understand it's not just me i
have a full
army of winners behind me they're in the
comments right now
saying winners only please like i have a
full army
of winners do you not see the rankings
they're on the rankings for a reason
so with that being said with that being
said kelly i'ma take your money i'm
gonna take your money
but let me get into these picks here we
go starting off the parlay
this week we got lebron james over
eight and a half assists shout out to my
guy
gingerbread the gingerbread man he is a
bonafide sharpshooter
every week he's on the rankings list my
guy
is a winner shouts out to him for that
one you know i'm moving on cabbie and
kelly you know they got dennis
sorry what was that you know they got
dennis shooter to pass the rock right
they just they just picked it up they
they got i'm gonna get there
i'm gonna get there i'm gonna get there
hold on let me let me talk about lou
williams first though
lou williams you uh my guy matt
dodger matt dodgers sitting number two
on the rankings list
he sent me uh he sent me a dm talking
about greg
lou williams over 15 and a half
points is looking nice so i'm gonna rock
with my guy
matt dodger and lou williams over 15 and
a half points
uh cabbie now to your point dennis
schroeder yes
they did get him for a reason to run the
point they got him because
they got him because he's a dog right he
got him because he's a dog
yeah i saw i saw his over under total
sitting at one and a half for uh uh
three points made he was sitting at one
and a half and i'm like one and a half
he only needs to knock down two in that
lakers offense
what why not so i me greg
took the over for dennis schroeder
in three points maybe hey taking the
over greg are you do you ever take it
serious question do you ever take an
under yes kelly i just bet the under
yesterday
when i yeah yeah i just bet the under
yesterday in the game yeah i'll talk to
you offline about this
back to the parlay kelly you're i see
what you're trying to do i see what
you're trying to do
you got the kobe mentality you're trying
to distract me right now because we got
this 500
bed on you're trying to distract me but
i'm back to the parlay here we go
uh my guy brasco tapped in my guy brasco
tapped in and i was like yo b i need i
need something man i need something for
the part that he was like man
i think kawhi leonard is going to ball
so
kawhi leonard is sitting at 26 and a
half points
he said take the over we're rocking with
the over with kawhi they need to make a
statement tomorrow they have to make a
statement did he load managing
two months enough for him to load manage
than to carry the celtic or the clippers
for more than 27 points
i'm just asking i mean
i i guess so cabbie we're gonna see
tomorrow he he
he he has to show up the way they looked
in the bubble the way they ended their
season in the bubble he definitely has
to show up and make a statement tomorrow
greg
i'm in the comments real quick and
all these guys hate hate that uh i like
the unders but i
i i really seriously think this is
really funny
uh why take it under because these half
these guys you're paying a premium for
their name
you're paying a premium to be guys like
hawaii leonard
and lebron james you're already getting
a half of assist here or another
look i'm not giving any of these dudes
hoodies they don't know anything
kelly kelly's trying to play mind games
on me cabbie but it's not working it is
not working
it is not working i'm back into the
parlay we have to finish it off okay my
guy
sbk sbk he went undefeated yesterday on
the story
sbk i tapped in when i'm like bro i need
a pick like come on holla at me he was
like i got you g
do not worry anthony davis is gonna ball
anthony davis is going to ball anthony
davis is going to ball
so anthony davis over 26 and a half
points
we're rocking with it i'm fully
confident in this parlay right here
i i'm fully compensated right real talk
there's a better chance that you're
gonna hit one of those 90 mile an hour
fastballs than this single game
partly hitting for sure are you near a
batting cage i mean you better get in
there
and if you if you do both we can do both
we can hit 90 and we can hit parlays all
day baby because
you know what i do win baby that's all i
do is win win with no i'm just kidding
but yeah
come on good luck all right either one
all right
so it's not 23 to 1. it's 23 to 1. this
parlay is 23-1 i just want you guys to
know that
parlay is 23-1 that's legit so
now that you've completed the parlay uh
jump in the comment i know you have your
your winners only wednesday's crew but
jump in the comments see if anybody is
taking that
for at 23 to one on fanduel
which is good value but i mean i don't
know if you're gonna
all i see uh all i see is is people
ripping on kelly in the under basically
kelly and gabby don't like any of those
kelly realizes greg knows what he's
talking about
trying to get him off track come on
let's see we need
cousins that's a you got the wrong show
buddy this is an nba show
i got some soldiers behind me and my
soldiers come hard kelly and cabbie they
come hard
all right but uh let me let me give out
some hoodies all right let me give off
some hoodies let me give out some
hoodies
i got shimmy burger in the comments greg
don't let kelly get you off track
it's also snowing outside and i need a
hoodie shimmy burger you're walking away
with a hoodie
uh locks underwater greg is getting paid
500 shouts out to you bro uh
thank you brother you're walking away
with a hoodie td
uh td neil underscore br he says he love
it
well guess what bro i love you too
you're walking away with a hoodie
uh cabbie just let me know when you want
me to stop there one more
thing in the comments or more comments
be in the comments b
flocking is in the comments he said uh
we ride baby we are riding
it looks like he's riding with my parlay
so uh
i'm riding with giving you good luck to
you greg you're gonna need it it's a
long
long season and uh i'm gonna put i'm
gonna put cabbie and i as like
three four five dollar favorite this is
gonna be this is gonna be chill
oh so basically so basically if i win if
i hit a parlay
it's paid three to one right that's that
what you just said
yeah we're gonna give you 500 bucks you
hit a parlay
you're gonna get a bonus you're gonna
get your parlay payout you just said
this one's 23 to one
and we're gonna give you an extra five
hundred dollar bonus we are okay we are
i thought
i i thought you were gonna i mean you
don't have to i'm going to cabbie
he's not into parlay i'm not worried
about it you know i'm not worried either
i'm not wearing either
okay listen well thanks to uh g-money
soldiers who tapped in
thank you to the commenters who tapped
in uh to the group chat presented by
fanduel
live in the bleach report app remember
what you learned today
when charles barkley guarantees anything
we bet the other way don't mortgage your
mustache
on your wagers or don't mortgage your
mortgage on eddie wagers
and no captain to your friend uh
alongside kelly stewart
greg ivory my name is cabby richards we
are leaving the group chat
good luck with your wagers
foreign